The
U.S.
It doesn't it.
I'm fine, I got a stinger, ayy, ayy, how's it going, I got a stinger, leave me, leave me,
ayy.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon, here's the game counts.
Uh, Sheevie's currently live right now with Elden Ring, the blessed background music.
Is this still playing?
It is, see that was the problem.
That's the problem when you use your background music, you're in trouble.
No, we're not even started, jeez.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon, how are you?
Did you sleep?
No, I was up fucking getting a new manager.
Um, there's a manager that's coming in, so I essentially don't do anything at the
show, shout out to my stinger, you are a real one, turns out my other stinger is broken,
so the best you're getting is the little seashell one, which is really cute, I think
it's a cute one.
Um, no sleep, no, I was up all night, I was having a fucking good con, so my girls were
asking for a manager and I was like, I couldn't really justify it, but then there was a major
communication error and like, you know, a lot of things happened and it was all over
a miscommunication, like a misunderstanding, and I'm like, so the plan was never for me
to be on the team in terms, like all the time, I was essentially going to be like an advisor
in terms of like content creation or things that might work out, um, it's not even yet
by, it's just a misunderstanding, I'm like, I checked Marshmallow and it's like, fucking
someone sent 10 minutes ago, I hope you're happy with your money, like, you know, you'll
learn that there's more to life than your money, and I'm like, is this over the fucking
fanzly situation?
I'm like, I can assure you right now, I have not told one fucking girl to quit fanzly,
like I can say that, as I said, there was clearly a miscommunication, and it was taken
the wrong way, and I've just been absolutely fucking like dragged through the filth and
I'm like, you know, it just feels frustrating, because, you know, you give it your all and
it may look like it's been three months of give it my all, but obviously, you know, when
you're cooking in the background, it's months and months before as well, um, like, obviously
like I blocked and moved on because it was like, don't be so fucking stupid about like,
oh, this is clearly for greed, I was like, there's not to fucking spoil anything, but
there's a really big development in the works that was decided very shortly after debut
and paid for by me, surprise, surprise, and like, there's projects ongoing, and you know,
the girls get what they want, and it's just like, just a really shite situation all over,
um, and it's just really annoying, because it's like, can when you try your best, that's
one, and it just like, fucking like crumbles apart, because of a mis-input is, it's just
bizarre, like, I didn't even know how to put it in a words, sounds like Twitter drama,
yeah, I was like, oh, where'd you do that thing, and it's like, maybe physics accounts
for faffing, and I wanted to defend myself, I can assure you right now, I never told anyone
to, I didn't randomly tell one talent to quit the website, but everyone else can miraculously
stay up, like, sorry, I'm not tolerating it, then it'd be silly, that like genuinely, then it'd be
silly, um, that's the annoying thing about being like such an open agency, is that
someone can say, what the fuck is that, um, someone can say one thing, another talent can
say the other, and then it's like, I get the blame for everything that goes on at management,
where at the end of the day, my responsibilities are getting less and less, I was never supposed to
fully be on the team in the way that I am, um, like, there's about to be a manager coming to play
in that, eh, and someone that handles the audios, and I'm legit just gonna be a streamer, so I guess
this is my note, if you have any grievances, then I bother using my marshmallows, I'm off the team,
go use the website, because like, this is just silly enough, and bonds broke over less, the fact
that you keep things together, I just, it's just silly, that's like, I'm not really, that obviously,
I'm not that pleased anymore, like yesterday I was upset about it, but today I'm like,
you're kinda not even seeing the picture at all, and it's just like, hopefully when this like,
secret event that comes out, and the secret project that comes out, it's like, well obviously it
wasn't for fucking Grigiamong, like honestly, just the, what the fuck, what is this, pick up,
okay, we have a physics engine, and our beloved game gas station similiar,
eh, oh, there's a piece of paper out there, not to get excited, but this goon cave could really
be spruced up about it, you know, right, oh, I don't know, some people hide behind the shadows,
oh yeah, like, I can't get out, had a little too many cups of honey tea,
no, like, I'm so sorry if you've sent me on Marshmallow recently, I've literally been too
scared to check them all over this like, fucking, miscommunication, and I genuinely thought people
would be, you know, wise enough to, of course I didn't randomly tell, like, what's going on over here,
it's dancing, it's so tantalizing, what are you, oh, it's a generator, I want this though,
none of us we've been thinking it for years, yeah, like, I just, then you can, how you go 20% of
coyotes, you found a card, okay, those are cards, hey, thank you for becoming a membo,
that's a true fake one, it's just gonna start driving me, you depressed on purpose,
because they read all of my emails, yeah, like, I've never had time to, like, look at them,
like, I too, I can't believe it, oh Christmas, I did so much work in the background, like, for
myself and future content, and like, one hour later, I opened up my Marshmallow and it's like,
why do you hate Mercy in particular, I'm like, what the fuck are you going on about, and like,
I met, obviously, Mercy, I'm like, hey, what's going on here, and she told me some things,
and I was like, oh, that makes sense now, because that was really unexpected, press P to open photo
mode, yeah, let's take a picture of that, okay, we don't need that, follow the high voltage cable
to find and turn the electric, what the fuck, I thought this is like, gonna be like,
supermarket simulator where it's all ready to go, hello, follow a voltage cable, this, this,
follow a high voltage cable, I mean, I wouldn't put my hand on it, so I consider this high voltage,
isn't this not where I just got that calling, you don't have to apologize for the idiots who got
bought her, I don't know, like, it just kind of feels like one of the situations where,
unironically, the fucking Captain Picard quote, and it's like, you can do everything right and
still lose, that's life type thing, I was like, of course I don't hate them, of course I don't
want them not to make money, of course this is like, just, it's just silliness, and like,
oh, I know streamers not supposed to show weakness, I thought an uncle,
since you've heard my voice now, hasn't it, yes, I'm a busy person, but luck would have it,
that the land you've purchased once belonged to my father, since you are not only a potential
business partner, but family no less, I'll do my best to help you, I will send you
emails on a regular basis, providing you with information on how to handle the Japan business,
decided not to do other website, but management never asked that, it's not like we went to one
talent and said, he used, stop, it was like, no, it's completely up to her, it's absolutely
completely up to her, and I can say this now, I put an update in the discord and said, do it as
much as you want, because I tried to explain like, hey we can't invest in zero percent of nothing,
and that was kind of the thing, but not my terms, and this is not like super market
simulator, when you can do what you want, and it's not as good, oh it's got both of his,
Mr Roboto, Roboto, a small hiccup, literally, what the fuck are they on about, and no one has been
forbidden, and it was literally a simple like, oh hey here's a few points I wanted to raise,
and everything's a discussion, it's not like some random fucking dictatorship, what the fuck,
how, I thought this was a super market simulator game, what is going on, achievement unlocked,
ruddy, ruddy what, what am I supposed to do, I'm just following the question marks on the maps,
no fuel, and you'll never guess what I just purchased, if I've got any fuel,
yee-haw partner, literally what's going on, is this already, no smoking stop motor,
are you squidding me right now, that's well, we just got a flood you with more love to balance
the scales, I don't mean talking about it, because I know, oh my god, streamers are not supposed to
ever acknowledge that they've ever felt sad for one day or one second type thing,
but it's like, I've had three months of not like, not one bit of negativity, and then one fucking
miscommunication resulted in that, I'm like, Jesus fucking Christ, I've not got like a slight bit
of grace, like originally the manager, I do love following the question mark games, this is really
looks like my summer car american edition,
what's this, why is it so low, checkpoint, oh it's not a save,
marks and spinsters, 1-88, sorry I shouldn't call you that because I thought you meant,
eight minutes, thank you, the booty lord, are you certified to run that piece of equipment,
absolutely not, Osha is afraid of me, okay, don't show sad, literally like I've had three months of
just like, did I not, press tab to open tools, is this an old school pump, I think it is,
um, Osha's the reason why strone exist, no strone is the reason why Osha exists,
um, empty, press tango from, no, I don't, how do I put you down, tab, no, take out your hand,
and then go inside, current task, return to removing the sand pail, okay,
what is this, oh my gosh, I'm like an actual man, oh, the old ball and chain, how do I do this,
oh I've already got it, it's already full, where do I put it,
ah, oh my god, I love games that have a big question mark on the screen, so you're not confused
where you need to go, I'm man on stream, it's me, I'm forklift certified, all the ladies want me,
and all the men fear me, oh shit, I'm fucking falling into the ditch, oh yeah, now what,
task complete, can I just leave, can I just leave this here, how do I get out, press F to quit,
yeah, I'm gonna just leave that there, thank you for your service buddy,
we have a code form, let me just drive in, it's Olga, right, I assume in order to get
customers in, we need to put the, there's loads of flies at the head, I dropped it,
roof painting, that roof is rather well put together, if you take into consideration everything,
whoa, okay, but yeah, I was, there was, so the manager was supposed to come in like,
either in a couple of months, or by the time Jen to happen, but I'm like, yeah, I'm not getting
shagged because of a misunderstanding, so there's gonna be a manager coming in, so if a girl's all
complaining about a manager, yeah, party or horror, no, not really, I'm still doing like,
the YouTube and script stuff and that, but like, actual responsibilities are not to do with me
anymore, because yeah, but I was always gonna end up like that, just couldn't do it at the start,
because it was like, I was like making shorts or scripting them, but then like,
was like needing to communicate, like, hey, I'm not gonna be making all the content on you, whoa.
Are you squiddin' me right now? Yee-haw, what in carnation?
Oh yeah, you're giving me positive affirmations.
Oh, you're giving me positive affirmations.
What if we positively affirmated over each other's faces all day long?
Dot gar, thank you for the super chat.
Plap, plap, plap, get positively affirmated.
I'm trying to make this place look thingy, but am I supposed to go back and forth like this, or
is there like a function where I can put some stuff, not one by one, because like,
I can't remember that Noah's Ark song, but it's kind of like,
she takes the planks off the window, herza, herza, she's walkin' to the dumpster, herza, herza,
and then takin' the planks one by one, soon the job will be done, but it's a thing forever.
Mmm, right, yeah. Had to do my first official block on Marshmallow,
that's when you know it's been going, actually, to be honest, that's when you know it's been
absolutely amazing, if you're three months in, and it was like, oh, the first ever block, um,
type thing, but yeah, I can confidently and publicly say I did not randomly tell one person
to stop streaming, but everyone else is allowed to stream on the website. Smile, like, I don't know.
I don't know what to tell you, chief. I'm not really sure what to tell you. We love you,
we worked so hard for us, Readlings, and the girls. Hey! Wait, that was the part of it.
Me, like, I don't pick. What's this? Is this the second location I could renovate?
There's a cement mixer and everything, and that's my house. That's a picture of my house.
Thank you, chief, for the stupid chat, man. A good way of looking at it, honestly.
Um, I know classic streamers are supposed to show weakness, but bro, come on.
Transfer between maps. You can now transfer between...
I've not even... We're still in the tutorial. I've not even set up on this map. Why are we teleporting?
Task complete. Refill your fuel supplies using the computer. Remember that time
is over called paper, computer paper. Whoa, wait, can I even operate when the place looks like this?
Are you squiddin' me right now? You are absolutely incredible,
mama, and don't let anyone else tell you otherwise. Love you and enjoy the love from the
reeflings. Heart, heart. Thank you. Squashy, not squishy, squashy. How do I clean this up? Is there a
burn? It says, test your skills on arcade. I'm gonna cough. I have a very dry... Are you squiddin'
me right now? Love you, mama. A reef same time. Thank you for having me. What is this? Okay, do this.
Thank you.
Have you set up a pilot boomer? What is this? Press space to jump.
Oh, that thing got something lying to it. Okay, press tango close. What did I do?
I wondered why that was so low. It's for the... Oh no, no, not more driving, please. Now you're
embarrassing me. No. We're not playing that mini-game again. I literally freaking got stuck
right away. Are you joking? That's so embarrassing. What's this? Your delivery has already arrived.
Open the valve to start filming the time. Did you just honk me? Open the valve?
That is embarrassing. I literally wasn't even... Are you squiddin' me right now?
You are doing a great job with what you are doing, Strony. We love you and we all know you
are doing the best you can. I'm beatin' up. No more fuel. Whoa. Okay, that makes a lot of sense.
Really, legend? Thank you. Yeah, like, it's just a shame because I was kind of hoping to like
still be lurking in the shadows a bit more, but... I ain't tolerating that again.
Serve the customer? Oh my gosh! What state are we in if I have to do it manually?
Because there's states where it's illegal. Grab the injector when client is waiting.
Fuel cap will be outlined. Turn fuel the car by interacting with the cap and the
left shift will boost the speed. This speed? Oh my gosh, we have to help you fuel because
it's illegal. Whoa. It's illegal for you to fuel it yourself. Goodbye, lady. Wait, did you pull the...
Did you leave this open or did you close it yourself, my good sir? Well, we'll be closed it.
She be raided? Where's the mark? We're in New Jersey? Any New Jerseyers? I don't know how to clean
this up. This is a mess. We can't use it right now. Get it quiet.
It looks like pills. A broom? A trash bag and spray? I don't see that.
Is that cream? If it was, hopefully she'd be enjoyed her LDM.
And yeah, is this how I do it? With the trash bag, you can do small garbage with this
and replace garbage bags and try to figure. Finally, you need to order garbage collection.
Oh my gosh. It's women's simulator. Wait, how did it become like that? How did I get rid of the
bigger items? They're so big. I'm trying to clean up. Oh my goodness, there's like...
Who would have been a perfectly good traffic cone? What's going on here?
I'm sniffing out the rubbish.
Hello bunnies. Bunnies. Here on my tangle. Are you squiddling me?
And then my hands out. I know what.
Misk65, thanks for becoming a... Is Brian shy? Are you squiddling me right now? Oh, right. Okay,
that makes sense. Dearest mama, we reeflings love you unconditionally and we all send you a
hug filled with lots of love. You are amazing, heart.
Are you squiddling me right now?
Could be waited for Kotel, but mighty as well. Praise the Kotel fish. Cast out the heretics of
hate. And lord of storms, thank you for this literature. Oh, it's Kotel. Oh, yeah. Right,
everyone, look alive. It's the polis. It's the polis. We've been naughty boys. How does it look?
Super. You just have yourself a good way, officer. A good day, shit.
I'm sorry, I spilled my spaghetti. Don't come back. I don't know how to speak. Right, how does it look?
Garbage, tab, bin bags, grab, hand, grab.
And then the dumpster is out back. Dispose of filled trash bags and old furniture.
What, just random shit? Dispose of filled trash bags and furniture.
Mm, I hear them.
Hey, I'm going to be honest. We were just trying to talk Kotel fish or made up fish.
I made a fishy. Made up.
Choose your teammate. Oh my goodness. Is this a gen two reference? An armadil?
Oh, my God. Oh, my God. I'll have that later. Have that the night. No, where's the snake? Oh,
he went under the bed. It's fine. I thought I killed the snake. Let's put it here.
Hey.
Pig girl peak though. No, we're not having a piggy girl.
I think if I joined an agency and they gave me a pig, I'd be like, excuse me? Right, what am I supposed
to do? Am I supposed to just look at random stuff and bin it?
Dispose of filled trash bags and old furniture.
Biggest piece of junk trash bag and old furniture need to be thrown into a large trash.
So this doesn't count? Like, these don't count as you know. Oh, this does. Okay, right. You, bin.
Tire. You, bin. Oh, I get it now. It's literally asking me to clear out the shot.
Why didn't you just say that honestly? Oh, my God. I'm getting blank flashbacks because of
these stupid steel. Ah, I'm in the bin now. Hold on a minute. Is this her? Is this the room?
Are the reeflands inspired by fortnight cuddle fit? No.
The concept artist came up with everything.
Um, Emmy was the only one that got her design changed. Um,
on pin pals and like, you know, I'd rather everyone just be happy with what they're
doing than randomly be like, no, that is not allowed type thing. So yeah, pin pals got changed.
If you want to see the old pin pal design, you can actually see it on, um,
her background music video because obviously the girls only got access to their like assets and
stuff. Um, like some stuff really, I can talk about the development at a later date about
what a nightmare it was.
Can you go in? In.
Oh, there's like garbage here too.
Buy a broom, press tab and equipped it. Is there even anyone here? Hello?
I'm, I'm so sorry for your wait.
I'm on.
Thanks. I'm so sorry. I need a broom now. Hello. Press left mouse button for our tools.
Yeah. So I thought this was going to be how, uh,
supermarket simulator played to taste a massive peach. I have terrible news.
Are you squidding me right now?
Right. Enough money. What's going on?
So, you know, how much love you have from us reflames? You've got at least one tuning in from
a construction site. Oh, please.
Uh, just in case you can't see the screen, I'm currently being haunted by Elvis. That's
actually really scary. Please leave me alone. What the fuck?
What? Is his grave like under here?
Aye, I don't like that. I don't know if that's supposed to be funny or not. That's actually
rather terrifying. I'm such a good speaker. Thank you, lonely, glizzy, what name?
Your glizzy looks lonely tonight. I can fix that. You look like a hard-working joe on your job site.
I think Elvis is giving this to me. Oh, can I? I'm just literally piling it up so much.
I know I probably shouldn't do it this much, but... Oh, geez. Uh, good evening.
Oh, out late the night, aren't we? Burning the midnight oil.
Okay, yeah. Now you have yourself a safe night, lady.
Probably shouldn't you be out at night?
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh, I've got a tip.
Do the restrooms here have glory holes? If so, are you going to be servicing them?
I had to sprinkle some out of pocket in this love soup. We got going.
What? What is this game? I thought it was about running up. I think it was, but I fueled it better.
Like, I'm getting achievements for this one.
Eh... Does that touch you? No.
I got deleted mid-read. Oh, no, what happened?
They had enough of you? I could still see the message.
Do the restrooms have... If so, are you going to be servicing them? I had to sprinkle out
some out of pocket in the love soup again.
Hey, Stronny. It's sad I just tuned in to hear about trollers coming for your throat.
Don't worry or we heard about it. I'm sure there were haters even before debut. Let Stronny cook.
Yeah, I think what it was is like, I was just so shocked because I was like, what's going on?
I think I need to ask for that to be taken away.
Because like, you know, you try your best for everyone's success and all that.
And it was just like getting bombarded for the first time and it was like,
it was really bizarre as well because it was like, why do you hate Mercy in particular?
And I'm like, what? Where did that come from?
Like, I genuinely couldn't put two and two together, so I had to try and piece it together really quickly.
And obviously, like, it was just so surprising. Like, obviously I can talk about it now because
I'm not as like upset about it or like hurt. I'm kind of like, so is, but I feel comfortable
enough to talk about it now, but obviously I can fucking talk about it another day.
Order garbage collection on the computer, which that's me.
I thought that, I don't know. I read that as a Pregnation.
I think there's a Zura tweeted out that she's going to do M-Pregs soon and I'll,
no, not M-Pregs. Sorry. The other one. The other one. The other one. Order?
Trash, order? I got...
I just get haunted by...
Uh, get the fuck out of here. Get the fuck out of here. How do I beat him up? Oh my God.
How do I beat up a child? Oh my God. I'm actually getting... Are you serious? How do you beat a
child up? I don't care if it's against the law. I'm coming out swinging. I'm actual coming out
swinging. Holy shit. I'll fucking, fucking curb stomping this child and forky. There's nothing
I can do. You can't beat him up. Are you serious? You can't beat him up. He's in... Uninteractable.
Are you serious? Open wade. That's right.
I'm sorry that you received Vile Maros over a misunderstanding. We refling support you always.
Oh, there's a card. Thank you, man. Right, no more... Am I getting attacked?
Did I just get attacked by a Cincada?
Right, I got a card. I don't know what they did. Oh, the city is in the distance.
Right, is there anyone... Oh no, please don't leave. Sorry. I was getting a bit distracted. Sorry about
the old... Right, ready? Like $46. Thank you. Wow, look at this car. It's clearly a Chevrolet
or something. I don't know what these are called. Hi, what are you? Oh, your garbage collection.
How do you beat up a child story? Real. Buy a roller in pain.
Oh, wait. That was a timed thing?
Once equipped through tab, press shift to select a clore, any clore.
We'll do green. Right, where the fuck...
What am I doing? Oh my god, I was having to edge the wall.
I'm forced to paint. I'm forced to paint even though it's already painted. I can't just leave it.
Oh, press F. Oh, this is going to take a hot second. Hold on.
What kind of minigame is this? I know it's a... Bro, this is giving the... What role am I playing?
The victim? This is painting. How have I got a minigame for that? What are you doing to that wall?
Honestly, I don't know. What is this? Am I just covered in paint now? I'm like...
It was the movie called, like, In Home Alone 2. One of them gets covered in paint, but I can't
laugh at the scene because if you look at his eyes, he very clearly either did have, like,
real paint on or something because his eyes are, like, so bloodshot red. And I wouldn't be
surprised if back in the old days, they never... I'm getting pranked by a freaking wheel. Are you
joking? Literally, there's this, like, meme and it's like, this is supposed to be a role-playing
game. What role am I playing? The victim? Because it's just, like, an absolute set. What? Who said?
Who said painting needed to be hot? Is this supposed to be, like, I'm so satisfied?
And so we're gonna keep it a Costco hotdog. That's how much it is to get access to the
area that our gas station serves. Actually, Ken Whit, we call it petrol, but for petroleum,
and you call it gas for gasoline, not to be confused with the hit Spanish word, gasolina,
which means... I think it means prostitute. I might have made that up, though. I didn't
speak espanol, so you'd know better than me. Eh, I'm afraid I've not been listening to enough
pitbull to know what it means. Oh, sorry. Do you? Don't you call it benzine? No, it's petrol.
Like, oh, I need to go get some petrol. Sorry, there's probably someone outside the shop right
now that's been waiting forever for me to fuel them up. Stop! You're getting ink everywhere.
It must be green. Okay. We're still going off! Still got boarded up planks on this as well.
How unprofessional this gas station, truly. But we're looking a bit more. Stop it.
We're looking... are you there? Hold on, let me get my hand out. Not to be confused with a hand out.
You're just doing the government assistance. You're not going to go over budget. No, I wouldn't
make you go over budget. You never asked for that. Okay, let's keep... let's keep... so benzine? What?
What? No! I'm painting you the wrong floor. Hold on. Uh, what was it again? Was it tango?
Shift. Shift green. Okay. Not one random bit being white in the front.
Okay, no. Everything has to be green because we're squiddles. What's up here? Okay.
Actually, I'd probably just make the rest of it green.
White. And then...
Okay. Uh-huh. Oh yeah. Yeah, look at that skill. Oh my god, that looks... look, this is an accent in
colour, okay? It's an accent in colour. I think there's a car behind me right now.
I would love to serve you right away, but I need to get this. Aesthetics of this place sorted out.
As it tries to debate me on the wheel. Right, we're doing the post and then we're done though, okay?
What accent is the colour? Uh, Scandinavian because it's white question one.
Wow. House flipper is this you? I've never actually played house flipper. It seems to be
like a really commonly played game, but... Well, I'd say it looks boring, but that's
hypocritical because guess what I'm doing right now? Probably the same core mechanics as house
flipper. So, can't he be chatting shite because I'm gonna get banged? I'm gonna get banged. I know
the good kind. I know the good kind with my eddy flints when we kind of like yelp at night.
What? Oh, it's a lamp. I thought that was CCTV. I was like, damn, we're back in 1984. Short and
behaviour. Absolutely short and behaviour. We did it! Okay, no more. Right, take my hand out.
And then...
Thank you, refling. See you later, alligator. And you go... Give it a little spank on your way.
Enjoy your journey, good sir. My good refling wife. Find the right tool to break into the car trunk.
A crowbar?
It was... There's another plane. Ooh, a plane. It's like when you come across a cow in a field.
I have a lockpick!
Please be like Skyrim or I'm gonna cry. Press AD to lockpick. Hold space bar.
Okay, it's like Skyrim. But does it sound like Skyrim?
Can't be open.
Has already opened it? Tangle? No. In my backpack, there's a dust bowl painting.
Favorite cell delete? Can I hang it up, maybe? Oh my gosh, let's... Oh my god, we'll make it a
conversational piece. So it's gonna go right there. Can I turn you off? You're so loud.
My little headset, my little gamer headset is too much. What's the most you've ever lost in a coin
toss? What's a coin toss? In a gamble? I don't know if you mean gamble.
Oh my god, refling stop. I like the green car. And you go... Everyone gets a spank at this location
when you go back and buy two shelves. Press left mouse button. Features, shelves of alcohol.
Let's do cola.
And then snap. Oh no, I messed up a little bit. Oh my god, that music's really annoying me.
Leave me alone. Is the shelves in here? Whoa, don't sell it, don't sell it.
Whoa, how do I rotate you?
Okay, I can't, I think it's... Q? Oh, geez, could you rotate any slower?
I mean, you have a grid like fashion, wouldn't it not just be easier to like maintain the grid?
Okay, and then, well, I'll take that. Okay, buy additional. Please stop. I don't want to use it.
It's so loud. It's so loud in my ears. Please leave me alone.
We play both kinds, country and western. What's this? Buy? I count before you clear the area.
No paint for the inside? Oh, and I've even thought about that.
Wait for the customer's order. Welcome to Rebecca's gas station. And today, we're doing this customer.
Oh my god, no, thank you. Right, how am I making like 50 quid every time one person show up?
Can I ask? I still need to clean this up more. I honestly thought we had finished, right?
What do I need to do?
Buying additional parking space. Right, where's Rudy?
Look for something yellow. Look for something yellow colored. Where is it? Over here, there is.
Okay, that'll do. Over the heat of the Nevada sun. Okay, press F.
This music no more.
It's my pee.
I see you pee.
Remember when that was the most hilarious thing at? Press left, mouse button.
Right, and then reverse. The pipes are hot. Jeez, these things are overheating.
Look for something yellow in a yellow colored desert, honestly. Maybe go in a sentence and turn it on.
Or at least if I can turn it down.
Right, hold on. Options, audio, music, even more because you're taking the mince. I've had enough.
Right, is that only supposed to clean that one? Or did I clean the wrong one?
I know it feels too quiet.
Well, no, it doesn't because I'm right next to it. Feet yours. Other, a parking lot. What do I do here?
Bye. One, two, three. What does that do? Do people come in for supplies?
Answer the call from uncle? Uncle, uncle, uncle, uncle. Go men, I'm sorry I was late.
Hello. Hi. I see the business is doing well. Sometimes. I'm calling to congratulate you on
successfully taking it off the ground. What? You can't run a business on fuel alone. I've
had a few of my people deliver some extra stock for those empty shelves of yours.
Time to talk money. You now owe me. Well, I'll send you the invoice to your email.
Don't miss it. I'm sorry nephew, but there is just no room for charity in this world.
I hope you'll find it within your finances. You didn't buy this place. I've rolled up and bought
it myself. Persuasive methods of reimbursement. Don't have me wait too long now. Goodbye.
I have five minutes to pay off five thousand. Bruh, I'm going to be.
What? Wait, so he stalked my shelves for free and I'm the one that gets punished for it. What are you?
I don't know about us.
He's still, I'm going to see him.
Good afternoon.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
If you won't read Marshmallows for a bit, then it'll just say it here.
It's just until it looks over.
You're an amazing person. This was embarrassing to say.
Embarrassing? You're embarrassed to declare your love for me wink, wink, nine thousand? How dare you?
Wink, wink, more like you didn't buy anything?
Militing? You didn't buy anything? Or is this like a self-gunner?
Serve the customers at the cash register. I don't even know how to get inside the cash register.
I gave you stuff you didn't ask for. No, where's my money?
Actually, she never wanted anything.
Good afternoon.
Good evening, because it's actually after six o'clock.
Are you out? You're out? Your engine's off?
Wait for the customers? Oh yeah.
I shouldn't have started that. No, it's literally the only thing my brain's going to be saying to the rest of it.
Yeah, yeah.
Is no one buying? Have I put the prices up too much?
Yeah. I'm going shop then, enjoy your shop.
Buy a bakery item to reward yourself.
Press F to pick up. What are you? It's just a club.
And now it's floating.
And why is it not allowed against this wall anymore?
We'll never know. We'll never know why it's not allowed against that wall all of a sudden.
Let's just pop it there, I guess.
Hi. I don't have... Why is no one buying? Can they not come in?
Oh. Is that bird shit? Oh. No. Oh no, I have to like...
I have to maintain the outside as well.
Okay, people ain't buying anything. I think I messed up the bone feature.
Am I supposed to go on it?
She put something down? She didn't.
Can you... Okay, you picked it up.
Uh-huh. How do I serve?
I'm going to serve this country.
What are you? The cash register.
Use shift in the belt and hold it.
Move products over the scanner and put them in the basket.
The belt will get dirty over time and slow down, clean it and hold it and make no mistakes.
What? Press...
I'm too small for this.
There's no products shown. Press F to quit minigame. Left shift.
Why?
Wait, how am I supposed to refuel cars and sell products like this?
Set up a delay. Oh, everyone act natural.
Everyone act natural.
Is that not sweet? Fine, you can have it for free.
Okay, I think I make way more money if people just take fuel.
So please just ask for fuel. That's great.
Cop founders.
It's the feds. Everyone behave.
How do I get in the toilet?
I must unlock it. I've got 11 seconds to make 5000.
Where did that come from?
I literally cautioned slippery when wet out of nowhere.
Excuse me?
You don't have to say that part out loud. I just want it in here.
I don't even know how to refuel for anything.
Are you a refueling? You're in all green.
Maybe Elvis gave it to you. Mommy failed to pay her debts and now she's owned
by the mob monkey.
Gava bun. It's a lot of life. I've only got two whole months.
Thank you for your extended membership.
I got a new emoteslaw.
I missed my actually drew that.
And then I put you on my head.
My emotes are coming soon to you.
Mercy to me and Acerus is the first.
Gaining?
Gil. Oh my gosh, you're actually using the...
Oh no, I'm going to have to actually empty it.
Have you not got any decency?
Elvis, you need to calm down.
This place is haunted.
Yeah, that's somewhat...
Elvis is feeling it.
You said put me back in for another one, chief.
Put me in for another one.
Yeah, ten dollar readers isn't really that much in terms of the gas station fuel.
Oh, I need to re-stock the fuel.
Uh, I can do that.
I remember how to do that.
Services? Not that one.
Home? More info?
Okay, uh, delivery?
Yo, do the math.
Oh, yeah.
Merry Christmas.
Okay, I'm not sure I'm digging the...
Am I being haunted by Santa?
I actually think I'm being haunted by Santa right now.
All yours.
Did Elvis laugh like Santa?
Yes, Santa's real.
You received a tip from a customer.
Aye, I'm not sure how I'm feeling about the...
I don't...
I don't make as much money if I'm on the tell.
I mean, I guess you make more money overall.
But no, the mafia owns me.
This is, like, the worst of both worlds.
Please don't look.
Sorry, it takes me...
It takes me a moment to figure out, like, they're all...
You think I would know after, like...
No, you know how that...
Where are you going?
No? Okay.
Are you just feeling a bit confused, are you?
I believe it.
I'm not eating.
You just do your thing, doll.
That was really random.
Is that why they kept walking back out randomly?
Who is littering?
Litterbug.
Okay, he's about to come here.
Oh, you have to go to work.
He just slams the tip on the counter.
Can you increase prices, as they say?
I think they might be so.
Oh, gosh, I'm going to say something contrary.
How do I connect the nozzle?
How did I do it last time?
It just, like, came out of nowhere.
Mm-hmm.
Wow.
E.
You'll never guess what it's E.
Oh, God, what are you feeling?
Okay, there's someone...
You ate their mess,
because it's a lot quicker for me to do this one,
unless they're actually buying fuel.
And then...
One second, madame.
Me?
Wait, what?
I don't understand a bit, Lord.
Can you blow up the oil tanker?
Unfortunately, I don't have a cigarette available.
He's already going.
I didn't know oil tankers even looked like a shuttle bus.
Like...
Hey.
Can I blow this up?
Hold on.
Let me...
Oh, my God, I'm going to emmy this,
like, in her lore video.
I'm adding a little pipe bomb
into it, a little surprise for him
in about 10 minutes' time.
Answer the phone call?
Hurry up.
What?
One, we're not even on the same freaking axis.
I got beaten up?
I didn't really like my uncle that much,
can that?
What?
You get beaten up in your own place of residence?
Why would I say that?
A loan shark got you?
I like the PNG that continued with the cigarette.
Uncle, long time no see.
You fucking...
Wake up, Sam.
You got a gas station to run.
Uh, is that all he's going to say?
He's going to get me beaten up,
comes over in his freaking expensive Cadillac.
So my uncle's a bad man, huh?
Hey, nephew.
Back on your feet?
I hope your head's no longer spinning.
Thanks for picking up.
We need to talk.
There was a mistake, a serious one.
I have the high ground.
You can rest easy.
No, and I will have the responsible people
dealt proper retribution for what has happened.
Wait, so that wasn't one of his things?
The investment loan deadline was rendered far too short
for what the amount was.
It's plain bad business.
And I don't make bad business decisions.
Let's forget about this debacle for the time being.
As a token of apology,
please accept this small gift.
It will help with your next delivery.
No strings attached.
However, you will need to make the warehouse
operational again to receive it.
Somehow, you're a resolute lad.
You'll figure it out.
Did someone say goon?
It's like whenever you watch Batman
and or something like that and it's like
get on it goons.
And I'm just like,
I think the word has been changed so much.
It doesn't mean what it used to mean.
It only means one thing these days.
Bro, I feel like there's just so much.
I don't know how to replenish this.
Surely.
A delivery of restock is locked.
Tools?
An airbrush, a vacuum, a few manic.
A few manic hammer.
Upgrade.
Unlocks the warehouse.
How do I get that?
Additional quest progression.
Gas station can touch this airstrip in party time.
Open closed specific sections of the gas station.
I'm tempted to close the parking spot
just so I didn't have to deal with the
which male
loan cash register alone again.
Oh, this is like summarizing
the plot that we're currently going through
because the game came with a plot random line.
Oh my god.
Hi.
Good morning.
Oh, hello.
Yeah.
Press right mouse button.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
What did I just do?
You owe my money and she breaks your kneecaps
for being late on your payment.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thank you.
See, you're a nice resource.
The pretty lord.
Thank you for the super chat.
I wouldn't break knees.
Most likely just spitting mouths and stuff of that nature.
Landmark decorations bought.
How do you do that?
Decoration.
Landmark.
I'm to buy this?
Sure.
How strange of a clue.
But mommy, we don't have any news.
I'll break your beak.
Cool.
Good evening.
I like how I'm on day four of no sleep.
Can you go to sleep in this game?
You might be able to.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
This reminds me of this one time I saw this cute cashier
at a gas station and my voice cracked so hard.
Still keeps me up.
Oh, Riflin, no.
That's so funny.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know why,
but voice cracks are the funniest thing ever to me.
I'm so sorry.
Lonely Kluzie.
Apologize.
That's so bad.
Shebe's like, count me in.
I'm beating them up.
I'm so sorry that happened.
And it keeps you up at night,
but that is really funny.
I don't know why voice cracks are like...
I don't think they're that much of a big deal,
but whenever there's like a clip,
it's like, no, excuse me, excuse me, type thing.
That's a skull.
Bro, don't let a customer catch me with this.
What the fuck?
Sorry, sorry for the confusion.
I'm getting a bit low.
I don't know how to restock.
Right, we need to figure out how to...
Oh.
Oh my.
I mean, I'll take it.
Oh my gosh, I got crazed.
I have been lip-raised.
That...
I'm gonna have to paint the exterior again.
I keep doing that and she's gonna be mad.
That's awful.
I dropped one item and you weren't charged for it.
Uh, literally.
How do you expand somewhere and then stuff just shows up?
That's not how it works.
That's not how expansion works.
What are you?
You're just a random cabin.
Get out of here.
I can't even fit through the down door with you.
Literally.
Customer, I feel sorry.
Cool that I've owned.
When your voice crack, everyone notices
and you want to die on...
I almost overcharged her ridiculously.
And Elvis is leaving his stuff everywhere.
Honestly, literally, what is this?
Just random bits and bobs?
Press F to pick up.
Oh, I got a free decoration though.
Oh, I like that.
Fill trash.
Okay, and then do that one, I guess.
And then...
Then you'd be honking at me, sir.
Where are you?
Get back to you.
Okay, get my hand out.
Oh, there's not even anyone here.
Go schizophrenic.
Oh, I'm going to be dreaming.
I've been dreaming of a garbage disposal.
Press F to pick up.
Right, and then put you against the wall again.
And then where was that other bin bag?
Get this tire out here.
Customers are going to be wondering what kind of decoration scheme we're going for.
Random cute toolbox holder.
That's actually really nice.
It's made out of wood.
We do love a good...
Find a way to enter the warehouse and open it.
Hello?
What are you?
Be careful.
Keep your warehouse gate closed.
Otherwise, folk are going to steal from you.
I'm going to close it then.
Reset the...
Reset alien?
What?
Remove the haystacks to make the warehouse operational again.
Can you open?
This is going to take me a hot second
if I'm having to do all of these ones.
What's going on?
Look, all it says is remove.
I didn't say put them...
Nope, that's a seat going.
Nope.
I just did remove the haystacks.
I'm getting trolled by a door.
Stop closing.
You're being so stinky.
Stop it.
Come out.
No.
It's too thick.
Stop.
Go.
Rotate.
Pivot.
Geez.
What is this fucking furniture move and simulator?
You have customers waiting.
No.
Hold on.
I'm mucking about with hay bales in the back.
Wait.
I'll fuck it.
Fuck it.
We have customers.
Refunds don't need to hire yet.
Oh my God.
Stop.
There's already two.
Right.
Let's do the gas first because they're the most money maker.
Okay.
Boom.
Oh thank you for your waiting.
Watch this.
Watch this scale.
Oh yeah.
Yep.
Uh-huh.
Tell them how you really feel.
Okay.
Next please.
Oh yeah.
Keep that clean.
Tell us how you really feel.
Okay.
We've bought some time.
Back to the hay bales.
That is a lot of hay bales.
Geez.
Think of the cows that could have eaten that.
Well someone please think of the cows.
Right.
Please get out.
Thank you.
How do I rotate this?
Come out with me.
There.
I'm just a shove against the...
Um.
Someone told you how cute your voice is.
My voice already allows me to get moving hay bales.
Oh or stuck or stuck.
Oh yeah.
Door stuck.
Right.
We're almost done surely.
Is this a Five Nights at Freddy's reference?
Or am I just making that up?
Have a really funny plot for Imi actually coming out.
I have no idea if she's gonna hate it though.
Fade out when she gets the square.
Do you want another plot?
Can I spoil it already?
Or am I not to spoil for me?
It's later.
Come on.
Come through.
There we go.
Leak it.
Um.
I wanted to do an in public kind of plot for Imi.
And I was like racking my brain what it should be.
Like I wrote it down in the notes and that.
And I was like how about you both at the cinema.
But you're watching FNAF 2 together.
She gives you the old gobby.
I was like yeah that seems on par for her.
Just trying to keep a secret challenge on possible.
I literally can't even come up.
Keep my mouth shut for like five moments.
Although I'm doing pretty well on the one thing that I can't spoil.
I'm actually doing rather well with.
Bomb head while watching FNAF honestly.
What happens on the roof?
Is an air vent?
Oh sir can you see by the dawn's air.
Right if I grab this.
Is this going to work?
Are you joking?
I've been making this so much harder than it needs to be.
I could have done speedrun strats.
You're making it so hard.
You mean nothing.
Optimization.
Real I'm sure.
There's beefing at me.
I keep you in brand and beefing.
Right now I've got $800.
What's this?
Warehouse.
Inventory capacity.
Fuel capacity.
Sure.
I started streaming 69 seconds ago.
Wait what?
Me?
No.
It's been an hour.
It's been in Deutschland.
Is the beefing someone waiting for fuel?
Maybe.
But sometimes they beef and they're not even there.
Maybe it's them approaching and it's like my head's up
that I'm about to need to serve.
Bunk.
Awesome.
Imagine getting a $5 to tip for literally pumping.
Wait do you tip for pumping gas?
No this cannot be true.
All right it's when someone pulls up to give you a heads up.
Okay that's fine.
I can handle that.
Customers randomly going out back?
Right can I?
Okay I can finally...
What?
All...
Oh no.
Okay head a head send.
Is it gonna come?
I lost it.
Oh okay.
Okay.
Okay okay okay.
Stack up and then order.
Insufficient warehouse capacity.
Guess I'll go F myself.
How about now?
Sell too much.
Okay let's start that again.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
That's what I actually need.
Remove one order.
Right jeez.
Sorry.
Product please.
Thank you.
Love a good bit of praise on a Saturday night.
Bunk.
Mmm.
How would we rate this game so far is the real question?
How many squiddles for a bluit?
So uh I...
How would we rate it?
I don't know why but supermarket simulator had to...
It had like I thought it was a child stealing.
I was like bro I don't have the capacity to deal with this.
Um.
A supermarket simulator was like way more addictive than...
Or is this one...
I'm not as majorly fussed for.
Is that controversial?
Uh one is exact.
Change while there's a tentacle.
Say no more good girl.
Don't answer yourself when the music's gonna do that for you.
You get yourself bagged you leave a tip.
You take...
You order takeout you leave a tip.
You're born as a guy.
You leave a tip.
Hold on.
Huh.
It only took me three months to get the applause sound effect.
Right.
So I need to let him in.
Now.
Oh yeah didn't he run me over mate?
You can run the chair over that's not to do with me though.
It's what now.
I have to unload it!
Where?
Oh on the shelves?
Oh right isn't...
Wait.
Uh.
Is that gonna close as well?
Oh he's tipping on his axis.
Jesus babe.
Gonna be our bumpy ride.
Can you close?
Okay it closes the other one as well.
I don't know what reset means okay.
I must be bugging?
I'm strange.
Calfish girl kidnaps you to our kingdom of warriors.
My win.
Real and true.
I found my super old script so...
I was gonna collab with Umi.
I'm both of us are gonna collab in another life.
And I found the script but it was ear licking and I had to see or I was like I'm so sorry I'm
gonna have to change it because obviously ear licking was fine at the time and she was like
no I completely get it like I'm completely put off doing it as well seeing like everyone
getting affected by it and we're all getting rolled and smelted.
We're all getting rolled and smelted by freaking ear licking.
YouTube why?
She's using me bams and I'm using this great bag bag.
And then do that and grab this then go it back.
And then scary customers are scaring me.
And then then get your paint out then press shift then make it green then print paint paint.
Wait what no what am I going mental?
Okay repaint repaint that's turquoise that's turquoise we need the dull green okay the dull
very dull green easy stay in the green I'm staying in the green sorry I know there's
customers waiting but legit they can wait so I'm trying to get my paint on over here.
Look ASMR please in your chair honestly.
Okay if we don't splat we don't have to clean up the paint afterwards.
Where's the cashier painting the store honestly there's cashiers doing everything at once.
Wait I have to redo the white pillars as well this is not fair.
That should oh no I don't that's where the white pillars.
I'm getting what is the mean it's what it is it's mean right tab hand you you
normally I would like recommend a game to girls if it was like a short easy game to play but I'm
like let's just show you I don't know I think I I think I misjudged this one I'm going to be
honest too I think I misjudged this one. I was looking up cult of the lamb and it looks like if
I could do it in one day it would be a big old endurance stream but tomorrow is me and embers
and through you and Juno which would be an interesting collab and I was such a cheeky
shit I was like can I ask for it to be done when I normally stream. I hear you like tips
well I got your tip right here pant scrabble love you goober you know what else is six inches
three of these I'm tea sorry don't thank you don't know if you think how do I restock
I mean we have quite the selection we've got two iron brews and a doctor pepper and that's the
how surely thanks for the tip right in order to restock refill the shelves with products from
the warehouse so press F to play oh my gosh what
no thanks but no thanks I'm not musically gifted like that how do I restock so the items are
definitely in here pretty first bear's pizzeria interact what
something's not clicking something ain't clicking right now I'm not sure what it is I just know
something's not happening yeah there's like new products I don't know if I should just
fucking hell are you in droids refling what I didn't ask for this you've been bitten
fucking hell your heart's about to explode you need to calm down on the steroids
Elvis piss off unless you're restocking the shelves
are you two unfortunately my brain can't seem to figure out how to
refill the shelves with products from the warehouse into warehouse products from
warehouse so what's going on what's the deal what's the deal is there some secret thing
that I'm not looking at with my eyeballs with my juicy cuttlefish w-shaped pupils
scrawny you too cute to be feared now that's a good one read the hint hint go to the shelves to
interact with it to place a product go to the shelves wait so I'm not supposed to even be in here
fuel status is low rails order new fuel
not mail not mail deliveries gas
or order interact place pick up
are you serious oh well I know this is a supermarket simulator are you serious
I've been farting about in that warehouse three times now
shawty behavior what's awful
Elvis Elvis stop haunting me I'm getting scared
no because actually why am I being haunted by Elvis Presley
what a very unique game fuck you I'm not dealing with that right now
are you scolding me right now honestly thank you again and on me please yeah
not no one else seeing him just haunting good mental through the doors
to be honest I know this is supposed to be junk but it looks like where I take my break
you know like oh I need a little break
oh my god we playing hi I don't think this one's me
geez some of us uh some of us know how to save the money right I'm gonna close
okay what was that timing right uncle you're putting hard work into keeping your station
I'm trying good good I wouldn't have it any other way I just wanted to remind you I'm not the only
one judging your performance he was a little hater your uncle knows better how to keep a business
going and wants to see you flourish right my approval only goes so far the real approval
you need to watch out for is the one given to you by your customers if word of slander gets out
you might even sell Egyptian diamonds for free and nobody will baton I keep those customers happy
here I mean popular gathering gather positive feedback for customers increase the popular
higher popular increases traffic which is a positive feedback can be attained by making it
clean and efficient um okay by fuel and just I can't get out
you know you don't have to pay full price for anything where's the fucking fuel
hold on did I not buy fuel I did you're are we
that didn't count I'm a dumbass I misread it I thought it was like yeah you're things done
nice nice cock
I don't know how nice wait why am I getting like these thumbs up was that always there
or is that like a new reward
nice well why is everyone being so nice
enemies to lovers nice that's a new me cat yeah I don't recognize that
me just meepin don't meet me
so I went out of bounds when I was mucking about
car
route soissonsis
oh no no what's this a workshop we fix cars later in the game as well
that seems a lot does it not
okay right let's get right into the steel truck is it coming
should come any floor
hashtag ignore popcorn officer gary oh no there's a hole in your restroom fix it or else
officer gary it's not what it looks like it's not what it looks like we're not that kind of it
I swear this does not work until I like I don't know if you can hear that in the microphone
like it doesn't connect
like that was
are you the driver right he must be the driver okay it literally is refusing to connect
you've got mail that's all my notifications are mail mail mail oh can get another yen oh okay
maybe need to expand the
I want a second gas station but I need to get a toilet a basic toilet keep it cleaner
else you're gonna lose more than you would ever hope to gain well I don't want to buy it then
if it's just more work I'd rather have more gas pump stations that's where the money seems to all be
expand don't
uh oh you won oh do you see yeah I bet you do
so when did we open the farming plots near the station there's farming in this game hold on let me
get a bird's eye view this I see a card I saw it wiggling
I saw it I saw you random prism is that a reference to that one movie with the apes and they'll go
oh another card so does this like get really big I'm just finding all the cards all right so that's
those are oil oh sorry
I don't know why that's making noise but
definitely the customer's waiting me who's halfway across the map right now look I'm just curious
that's all I'm just curious right back to the cafe and I guess I'll go back to the customer
this is massive this map
let's not start that discussion again aliens wait what what did yes but also it's a thing that
actually happened what did I miss have I missed some lore
awesome did I miss something what did I say
just on a life side quest does the client's wait yeah right where's Rudy did someone did someone steal
Rudy Rudy hello
uh something yellow
I've lost Rudy
go men sorry I've lost Rudy what
your forklift certificate certificate expired I think it did because I didn't
derive it anywhere else I'll leave it at the heap on purpose
I have new mail I always have new mail approval and popularity yeah
okay but where where'd my machinery go hold on I need to serve Lara Croft in the skies
go to the warehouse and press the spawn button oh
oh
hold on how much dust is there in this place dust sitting
okay great so now I can disappoint people okay I'm starting to understand we now have the
ability to disappear why were you all the way over here do you know you don't even have that much
fuel in you to turbo I can turbo in this yeah oh it's going to overheat it though
out my way you bums out my way you bums I'm expanding
oh it wasn't just one it was two
shock and behavior there was two on it maybe I should just get rid of all the sand like rain
guess guess guess we're gonna stop well it is a desert
or is that the bio of Nevada a desert I don't know why I went Nevada
okay am I gonna make it before having to refuel
surely surely I can make it over these two I just want this one
and then I can expand and then we can have more customers
it won't let me lift it
oh there we go there we go right so we can now expand if we so please
Nevada desert is amply named you know what when you say when you say it like that refuel and I
have to admit your words have some merit to them it's a very strange
just like hmm yes it's too hot that nothing exists here by the way it's like oh okay
really you're getting left because I got customer serial with I want to open up another fuel pump
as well actually
wham bam thank you ma'am for waiting so long
it's been so long you're welcome nice you're welcome back anytime because you had the
yeah you got Pringles that's fine right and then I'm gonna go on the computer and open up a second
fuel pump and then and I don't know is this is parking I'm not opening up a big steam and
I don't know if I even make that much on stop to justify the $500 fine
oh the next thing is a fuel pump
raw I don't know if I want to open up a shitter
fuck it we're opening it up right let's see what the state of this hole in the wall is one second
I've gone the wrong way it was a 50 50 what side the toilet okay no it was even worse than I imagine
fucking hell you nasty bitches yes
fucking hell would you shite on the floor in your own home
no you wouldn't have to freaking clean this I've just given myself like so much more work
how do I clean this is a brush I don't know how I clean that I have no idea
I don't see the hole is there like an actual toilet no there's like dirt behind it though
hello I'd like to clean the motherfucking dirt increase the station's popularity by one
and how would one do such a thing
I'd be worried we'd be stranded stranded
you're amazing my god that scares me so much
it reminds me of a borderlands the
cycle basically that's really scary please don't hurt me oh and he's glitched out
awesome oh his boobs tatted yeah you sure sure does
oh your tatted boobies whoa
who's getting their back blown out what the fuck
what was that
that was so random like the the fade to like dark and
incredible thanks those were not handcraft snap crack on pop your popularity went up yeah
that was you're amazing wait so did something happen or am I going crazy
who's honking honking for Scotland clearly
achieving unlock tip of the iceberg what's that for got a total of 50 tips during the mini game
it's a mini game to fuel up isn't that the whole concept of the game
so why did it show me this is this like rising from the sand
or something i didn't give it a clean
and they're like more popularity i have the more it rises out of the sand
that would kind of be cute though i'd approve of it the tip you can buy a workshop now
and the same try to start being powered oh i know that big folic fans have done
pilgrimages through Nevada following the route you take don't you not die out there
that seems rather dangerous you know a pilgrimage through like
what's happened here oh no it's my ranking from inside here gone down see use you eat litter
bugs honestly what would your mums be hinking
oh my god stop there's like so many
wait i'm getting like a high score for tossing this stuff in
i
who's strange
is that considered a minigame you just infinitely do that and you can get the minigame point
i'm sponging counter spongy oh that's cola oh speaking of cola hydration check
sometimes people people live there most lately to be killed and die from the elements
wait we can charge our thorough literally the yee olympics
hi thank you for waiting i was mucking about
uh pretty bitch what i am for oh a little car crash oh they're honking because they're crashing
into each other that makes a lot more more set relax you're in a parking lot so i don't know
i did not know i could do this whoa you're splayed
oh what is that a book come here mr bug i'm trying to find you
right workshop i can buy the workshop now it must be from the computer okay let's buy the computer
very quickly we will beep and then we'll buy the workshop and we'll see what that's all about
have a nice day yourself madame you're so kind honk if you love story calls oh that's
so cute bucket type thank you for the extended membership as well that was so cute right
warehouse no wrong one workshop restore for some money tire exchange mirror and scratch removal
not enough money oh i've been spending too willy nilly i've been spending too willy nilly hold on
hold on i need 500 i need 500 i can do it i can do it i can do it good afternoon sir
oh fantastic choice of fuelage yes no no you can't be stranded out from around these parts now sir
all right let's get 500 bucks that's still not enough
do i really have to bend this stuff it says my cleanliness in here is done a bit oh maybe it's
just that i'm sweeping the floor sweepy sweepy floors all right
uh huh uh huh come on give me 500 bucks come on someone roll up that needs fuel do you need fuel
no no uh i don't it's a rattlesnake i don't think you do great in the world
oh i'm not allowed to pet the rattlesnake i'm not allowed to pet your snakes speaking of petting
snakes is that thanks so much so i sleep on top of the warehouse when i do sleep we're on day five
so i've not had much sleep at all but whoops uh where is my pet snake he's a snake and there's
a bear is a wee husky that's quite cute terrible service managers slow three stars no i'm trying
to raise funds to change tires are you squid me you don't understand officer gary officer gary
please just give me another chance your hard work for us and the girls are most definitely appreciated
oh no how can we ever repay you drops pants okay that's so true though let literally that's so
true thank you sirian that's so good how oh no how can we ever repay you which oh no it's stinky
how is everyone producing so much rubbish right i think i'm gonna have to do a removal because
that's stinking that's like actual reason that having a fuel levels as well i think i wish you could
check fuel that press to interact yeah but there's no one here i need five hundred dollars oh my god
speaking of five hundred dollars guess who got scammed on their uh lego hobbit set i got a full
refund i'm very happy to say i got a full refund um you got a free item in your pissy
bro yeah so i was gonna my lego hobbit set arrived and i opened it up and i was like
something doesn't seem right here um and there was a missing packet but then i look at the color scheme
and like the packets are all the wrong color they're not even hobbit related like the hobbit set has no
red in it and like this i don't know what it's supposed to be it's like neon red and um i contacted
them and um they were like oh my god you're getting a full refund we're so sorry um because it was a
reputable like source um and they said like we're we're so sorry we purchased um like sets from folk
um by this one cellar in particular um and we've basically discovered that i don't understand
the scam either like they take random lego parts away um and like mix them up with other ones to
sell to resellers but like i don't even know how it got so under the radar it didn't really make
sense but i got a full refund so please don't worry i got full refund um and waiting for the customers
all right um the the hobbit hand cam
how much no i finally have 500 and my fuel is low i'm gonna do it i'm upgrading the workshop
i'm sorry but i'm doing it i know i have four freaking go away Elvis i know i have four dollars but
when i need to order more fuel but sorry you've got a new mail okay uh congratulations i ain't reading
all that uh i'm going to need someone to very kindly look how is that even falling out to be
honest there's so much room inside the the dumpster i'm dumpster in the cell
we almost got in trouble we almost got caught in 4k so how can i not clean behind here like i can
just never clean behind here Elvis knows not the time
no there's a kid spray painting outside i can hear his giggles
i don't have time to be pranked like this
no adding cameras to the bathroom he didn't wash i fell her dumpster till up
Elvis stop peeking into the toilet
i'm writing you up for poor property management officer gary give me a chance it's the officer gary
go do your job look i literally for legal reasons i literally cannot beat this child up
oh look he's let he's leaving biohazards behind as well officer gary you need to do your job
i pay taxes which goes into your wages so i don't know why you're getting cheeky with me i actually
didn't get why you're getting cheeky with my officer gary incredible i don't know maybe go arrest
the ghost that's been harassing us as well while you're at it i actually i'm coming for you
is there even not enough money how not then how could you put it in
customers at the garage oh no uh hi what would you like
uh
Voila!
Neat scratch remover?
This is an item I buy?
Uh...
Scratch remover?
Those are mirrors.
What?
Ray, I can replace your mirror.
Ray?
Neat wheel?
Yeah.
Um...
I don't have?
What?
Hmm?
I think I'm going to have to let you go, Mr. Customer.
Sorry.
Press live...
What?
It's there?
Is it there?
Oh, this?
Can't grab it.
Right.
Uh...
I'm like, I think we just release them. Look on the wall with the trash.
Tires.
Oh, they're right behind the thing.
Okay.
Eww, eww, eww, eww, eww, eww, eww, eww, eww!
You know, for someone who is hired as a gas station attendant,
this is rather out of my thingy.
Right, that's the tire.
So then what's the buffer?
What buff?
Trash doctor, okay.
I'm just coloring in.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, right.
That...
That could have gone a lot worse.
That could have gone terribly wrong, but it didn't.
That's the main thing.
I did not know you could do so much on this game.
Right, we have unlocked all, like, three delivery sections, bro.
Services, paint, and you can just hire someone to test things.
Overall revenue, 3K.
Gore?
Hi, Gore.
What?
How are you first place at 11 seconds?
Got it.
That's not even possible.
We're getting trolled.
Right, we need more fuel.
Can we do more?
Not enough money.
How not?
I'm ordering the maximum on purpose.
I know the fuel is low.
And the car wash.
There's a car wash?
That'll do.
That'll do, right.
Delivery, fuel.
Add $100?
No.
That much?
There's a fuel pre-system in game?
The government needs to...
Whoa, that's bizarre.
I did not expect that.
I did not expect that to randomly have a subsidizing thing.
I'm trying to keep this place clean.
Everyone's making it so dirty.
I think Shibi's actually about to do another stream.
Unless the gorilla was her stream for today.
I'm not sure.
There's a lot of it.
A car wash and an airstrip as well?
All on the same map or on a different map?
Because I hope I have enough fuel for you, sir.
I do.
Super.
This game is like six in a trench coat.
A gorilla?
A giant gorilla.
Just like in those old video games.
I got no occasion Shibi's stirs is going to do doom.
Damn, two and one.
Wham, bam.
Thank you, ma'am.
Why is the litters not gallant?
Customer, do this.
No, no, nothing.
I don't know.
Unless I can like super fastly do this.
I'll take one bikini care wash please.
Bikini care?
Am I allowed to be in a bikini outfit?
I've got like a little countdown going prepared.
Right, show me what's wrong.
Wheels?
The wheels on the bus go around.
Right, let's get rid of that.
Whoa.
In the desert there is...
I don't know what's going on in that bathroom,
but you better get out in the next two minutes.
I'm not cleaning up after that.
Okay, and then you want new wheels?
I can give you new wheels.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Strange.
I think I'm bugging out a bit.
And then put the new wheel on.
Yeah.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I'm lightning McQueen.
Nope.
And then what other one is it, ma'am?
Look at this one.
Oh, jeez.
The tread on that tire, ma'am.
I'm afraid that's going to be $300.
Mm-hmm, they'll never know.
Is that everything for you, ma'am, for today?
Yes, thank you.
Right, okay, hold on.
I need to put the fuel.
Fuel, fuel, fuel, fuel with some blues.
Press E, press E, spam.
Oh.
Wait, he puts the pump line in?
So you're the one who's been taking forever.
Who's put blood on the floor?
Hold on.
Why is there random blood on the floor?
You're welcome.
That better be a crisp packet, I swear.
I'm not dealing with that.
Good job.
Thank you.
Why?
No, they modeled that after Elon Musk.
Yeah, sorry, they modeled that after Elon Musk.
I'm not taking it any other way.
Not really, but...
How can you work here?
I'm a literal one-man army.
Please relax.
Who's shitting?
Right, who's shitting?
Which one of you nasty fucks are shitting?
Are you honking at me?
Because it's no me.
Okay, we have fuel again, at least.
I touched it.
Thumbs down?
Is it really that bad?
I wasn't paying attention, but was it really not, though?
I'm 5K in debt to the mall.
Please understand.
Car parts delivery?
Fucking hell!
Do they actually have a whole...
I'm already out of wheels?
What?
Great job!
I am doing a great job, thanks for asking.
Right, let's close the business and wrap this up.
Right, get that light off.
We're no longer open.
Everyone go home.
Close.
The entire gas station is closed.
Everyone go home.
I like how the car...
Wait, oh no, he's turning in.
Did the people still want served if they were coming in?
Whilst it was closing, is my question.
Stop honking at each other.
You're literally on the car park.
You're under investigation for murder of who?
I wonder if bodies decompose faster in the desert,
because it's like all bugs and stuff.
Right, so everyone goes home.
Good.
Oh my god, you're right.
There is a car wash!
So then, who or what is the air strip?
The entire gas station is closed.
Right, well I try not to embarrass myself this time
and actually do the little race car thing.
Then we'll redirect into...
I don't think...
Oh, it was this.
Okay.
Right, let's just take easy, okay?
Let's do easy.
Easy, steady.
Oh my god, we're losing it.
We're losing it.
The turning on this is very strong.
Okay, uh-huh.
Yeah, easy.
Easy on that turn.
Okay, very strong turn and very strong turn.
Just half it.
Just half it a little bit.
That's all you gotta do.
Okay, I did a much better job this time.
Okay.
Oh, no, no, don't lose it now.
Don't lose it now.
Come on.
Easy.
Slow and steady wins the race.
I'm just following the curves.
Hold it together.
We're going off-road a little bit, but that's okay.
Let's stick to the path, okay?
There's a reason the road has been carved out.
Stick to the path.
Stick to the plan.
It's like the skill in.
No, I'm not doing the ramp.
I already know I'd be upside down by the end of it.
14, 15, 16.
And last but certainly not least, 17.
Achievement unlocked.
Complete the race.
Aw, that's cute.
There's a good little truck.
You're a good little truck.
I don't know if I got all the cards in the area.
Right, so I went on the restart.
Maybe there's like one more card,
because I never got all the achievements for the cards.
Only thing strongly murdered was my tentacle bouncing on it.
Oh, that's so good, honestly.
How did your tentacle die in the Great War?
The Great War?
Yes.
And what kind of war?
I couldn't have won.
I was implausible.
Wait, what?
Is this out of, it is out of bounds.
Wait, what does, what's the warning say?
Oh, you'll be returned to the gas station.
Currently in gas in a minute.
I thought, oh, is this the last card?
Dennis Fort.
Wait, was that the, okay, that was the entrance.
Sorry, that was the entrance.
Wasn't it paying attention?
You found a card.
Are they getting achievements for all the cards?
No, I guess I don't have them all.
It died in the Great Clam War.
Oh my God, yes.
No, right, go back.
Sorry.
All right.
And I can't go across the road.
Can I?
I can go across the road.
There seems to be a structure over here.
Nope.
Can't go there, right?
But I don't have all the cards.
I find that hard.
Unless it's buried under sand.
Maybe.
No, that did get all the cards.
Where's my achievement?
Come on, give.
I got all the cards.
Well, let's see if we played the, that game.
This is like a maze, a random maze for the mini-core.
It's like a terrible game of golf right now.
That is Dennis's fort.
Time to leave a massive jailbreak.
Wait, why do we hate Dennis?
Is that a reference to something?
Okay, that's pretty fast.
Right, let's go back to sleep.
We've not slept for six days, so let's go up here and close the door.
Oh, we don't even have a door.
Oh, that's nice.
Let's just pop that right there.
We'll kind of scooch that in all over there.
Oh, we can't even, we're not allowed to sleep anymore?
We're not allowed to sleep?
Fine, I'll just crouch on the bed then.
Golf with your friends, so lovers.
He's the graffiti kid.
Oh, they probably is.
No, you're right.
My technical dad kind of buried in your storage.
The other cards might be later gas stations and like an area of it.
No sleep, just work, literally.
Oh my god, my wee mic's ready to come flying off.
Please don't die, Mr. Microphone.
We breached through the strong gold, but the clam guard was too strong.
You can't even sleep, it's just pure exploitation.
It is, I don't know.
Hold on, let me redirect him so she's straight.
Yes, yes, yes, I'm gonna step on the gas tonight as well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm gonna have to find the link.
Hold on, let me get a link for Sheevee's stream.
What was she playing? What shoot was it today?
I was watching her play Titanfall and I loved it so much, it was so cute.
I watched the, near the end where it was the big mech-off, I was watching that.
And she was doing so good.
I looked like the Vod broke, but it definitely worked.
Like the Vod, I can see 8 hours on Sheepster's Vod, so I'm not worried.
I think it's all good in the neighbourhood.
She's playing Doom.
BFG, big fucking god.
Touch-tash-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t
Thank you, Unknownmiss, for the tip of effedency and reluctantly sung and Officer Gary.
I'm really bad at saying everyone's names recently.
It's such a bad streamer, you need spanking.
All of a sudden I'm like, why, why are you limited out?
I'm just like a nice little Cut-Off, and these Cut-Offes.
The only thing they fear is you, rip and tear until it's done, plop plop plop plop rip and tear.
Get spanked, mommy.
But the cup is here, it means enough.
Did you see the short where I burped in your mouth and it was absolutely mingin?
That's right, I'm forcing you to watch it whilst we stall so we sheepsters to come online.
You're being forced to watch it.
You're not ready for this, literally but it, oh no, it broke for me.
I'm a burp right in your mouth, do I do apologize but please do open that some wide for me.
There you go, that's spanked.
Eee, you swallowed that, alright darling.
I must have been playing, I must have been playing, how do you call it, BioShock.
Because that's when I do the Atlantic accent, would you kindly let me take over your mind?
I already commented on it, oh god, I should reply to comments when, hold on.
As you wish, Johnny, you don't have to apologize, give a little, a little, a little part.
And I'll put, I aim to please, and then a little, a little blush emoji, I aim to please blush emoji.
Love this new technique for CPR, I think the, the base in the burp would really help restart the heart.
Exclamation mark, that's like only the third most disgusting thing Johnny's ever done to us, oh no!
Oh it's two, what is two and one, question mark.
She said the magic word, okay, cheeky sorry and everything is good to go.
No, no, no signature on a con, convision, niggin, ooooh, convision.
What, the, the flame thrower's are a legal piece of paper, that one.
What, I can't even say that word.
The flame thrower piece of paper where it says you're not supposed to burn people.
I've, my brain is not having it.
Number one will be the peeler relegation.
I did declare that burp was a bit fishy, honestly.
You can smell the soup, you're not!
No.
Thank you Mume, there's a lot of thanks.
Thanks for the meal.
I, well, I, da, tacky moss, and then I do a little pretty emoji.
Are you squidding me right now?
By the way, listened to the Scottish succubus audio last night and oh my god,
Morgan Anseland herself would be proud.
You actually, you liked it?
Thank you Odin Yakuji, you liked it?
I thought it was a bit shy, so I thought it was a bit shy, mate.
The Geneva Convention, that one.
You did tacky moss.
Oh, I'm glad you liked it.
It's a little bit rubbish about it, but hey Ho,
it just goes to show if you think it's rubbish, other people might not.
Like you judge it as harsh because you're the one making it.
So I was just, have some sprite, I'm going to say I should do the sprite separate challenge at one point.
You know, I think I said this, from my debut I was originally going to do the sprite challenge,
but then I didn't because I was too scared.
That people would hate me for it.
Both were amazing, loved the Billy one.
You did tacky moss.
Please don't thank me.
What's the sprite challenge?
You basically chug an entire sprite,
and you don't burp until you burp burp.
Can I hold up part two? Can I pull it out?
No, it's doughnut stacking for part two.
Yeah.
Challenge accepted. To be honest, I like the kissing and Billy doughnuts.
Cheeky bit of doughnut.
Me? Doughnuts?
Oh, this is scared not me.
I want to find out how many doughnuts.
I don't know how.
Strongly the booby builder.
That's funny as fuck.
Booby is slang for your tentacle in Scots.
That's hilarious.
I don't think I've taught you that, but yeah, Scottish slang booby means tentacle.
I agree with that.
The succubus and the glooming audio are tied for my favourite audio.
Oh, really?
Why do you think I named myself this?
Okay, that's funny.
Thank you, Groomed by Veeler.
We need to decide.
We're going to write the script for next month together.
I was taking a look at my notes.
After December, roughly, is when we can start fully writing the plots together.
Like, for the full month.
Yeah, based username checks that I see your manual culture.
I want to get going too.
Everyone's welcome.
Your booby broke?
No, your wee booby.
Aw, did you fire a wee bit early?
A wee bit too early for mummy?
Aw, your poor booby.
That must be so.
A wee bit raw?
Yeah, would be a shame if mummy kept put.
I love those memes that are like, when you inked but she keeps sucking and it's like...
And then the image is like something like an outer body experience or something like that.
But isn't that just P-O-T?
Like, a potted plant, codenamed potted plant?
Isn't that just P-O-T?
But via, you know, a tongue and stuff?
Question mark?
Isn't that not what all those memes are?
When Scoob licked all the peanut butter...
Wait, what?!
Off your jinkies but he keeps on zoinking?
Oh my gosh, like zoinks Scoob!
Oh no.
I mean, some people like that.
You haven't seen that meme?
No!
Wait, I don't know if I want to type it in.
Oh wait, I'm going to pull up the image.
Too early for...
Too early.
My for mummy.
Sounds questionable to me.
I'm so sorry, Broly legend.
I absolutely just like destroyed that.
I destroyed that sentence.
Wait, I'm going to pull up the meme.
What?!
Right, okay, hold on.
Let me show it on screen.
Give me a second.
I'm checking it twice.
I'm trying to see who's not here nice.
Cause Sandy Claws is coming.
Where is it?
This is the meme.
That is awful.
No more.
These are awful.
I should...
Oh my god!
I should do a meme review stream!
Oh my god, you have to send me like your memes?
Oh my gosh, and I have to rate them?
I didn't mind doing a stream like that.
I've just entered.
What the fuck?
Honestly, I was so sorry.
Your timing is awful.
This is me and Mumme.
Are you kidding me right now?
That's fucking foul, honestly.
That's fucking foul.
Broly legend.
Thank you.
Oh, Brian, even Brian's saying it too.
Meme review.
Viola meme or random memes?
I would say random memes.
I feel like there's not enough Viola memes going around.
I was thinking of doing that meme that I did in another life where it's like Spider-Man
is like slowly walking and he's upset, but I was going to do it about like me and the
gang, like get a new version of it.
I was going to do that.
Thinking audio, Mumme wants her fix and we give it to her, but it's been too long between
sessions and she keeps going cause she needs more.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, so not to get political or anything, but I read a manga about a cute little technical
thing and it was, bro, it was so cute.
I want to get one of the panels of us.
So not to get political or anything, but it was so cute and I loved it so much.
Now I want to get, now normally I wouldn't freaking touch this subject with a 10 foot
pole because I'm like, oh it's not for me, but in it the wee technical made her look pregnant
and I really liked the scene and I was like, oh no, what's going on here?
Oh no, this can't be.
I was like, am I gaining a new special interest?
So I'm not sure, I'm going to, the artist that I've been working with that she's like
absolutely fantastic.
She's actually going to be drawing something, I don't want to foil it, but you already know
what it is, if that makes sense.
Yeah, but once she's done with that, I'm going to commission my anime one where I'm foot stomping
you with blackmail and then I'm going to commission that panel shamelessly and it's going to be you
because in the manga it was literally you because you can extend your arms and that,
get preggers with gen 2 honestly.
We can make this a reality when Stoney's climbed all the ink from your tentacle but
she keeps on plop plop plopping, honestly.
I love how her Scottish son dairy has a weakness for cute things.
I love it.
Given Mummy Soda and having her bones on your tentacle, shaking her up and every time she burps
she grips, that's a diabolical plot.
I'm going to need 13 of them right now.
I'm going to need 13 of those plots, that's amazing.
Going to give us the pregg bus scene.
I liked it, okay?
I don't know why I liked it.
I liked it.
It was really cute.
Breeding gen 2 is why R&B has so much potential.
I mean it's happening, it was going to be an old audio on Twitter.
I'm not going to put it behind a paywall or anything like that.
Had there been an update on the chicken soup meme?
I'm still debating on it.
I'm not going to force it if my brain's like, I really don't want this out type thing.
Not that it's like bad or anything, but maybe I'll do a different thing.
Honest, thank you basically Wiz.
I can see that happening.
I actually commissioned an artwork of three reeflings with me.
I bought a few artworks in advance to do an event.
However, this new artist, I really like her style.
I think my little mini event's going to cost like $3,000 or something.
But it's going to be so worth it.
I'm going to be cheeky and see if she's willing to let me cut the head off of the artwork
so I can use it in YouTube roleplays as well.
That's six tentacles.
Yeah, an event.
Yeah.
I like doing stuff for you and fun little treats and that.
But I think it's going to cost a pretty penny.
But it's my, you know, I work hard hopefully to do it well.
Yeah.
And I'll see what happens, but I'm looking forward to it.
What about the tentacle shop?
I remember it being a bit better, but when I first started being a curator of the forbidden, you know, panels,
tentacle was like up there, but it is coming back.
Like I wasn't really, it was like my number one and then it fell out.
But it's like definitely climbing again because of you, Evelyn, basically.
I'm getting back into it again.
There's this VTuber that's popped up and she sometimes comes up on my feet and she has tentacle,
not enough from Hold Alive, this new one.
And she has tentacles like coming from her back and that.
And I'm just like, I want my alt model like right now where it's very clear that you are, you know, doing your thing.
Like I want your tentacles like wrapped around my thighs and legs and my tummy and that.
Like, oh, I can just picture it now and it's going to be freaking glorious.
It's going to be glorious.
But I must, I must wait and I must try and I must behave.
Tentacle and Joy are starting up.
Mommy likes their tentacles.
I only know three VTubers with tentacles outside of Halo.
Outside of Halo.
Halo Live announces their new concert.
With Master Chief.
No, I've been watching her because I think her design was a pre-made, but it was really beautiful.
I don't know what kind of content she'll make, but it was stunning, loved it.
I've been enjoying seeing her pop up.
We get to cling on to you on the alt model.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Brian, don't say that!
I can only get so hard.
Brian, you're not supposed to say it out loud.
The Buttey Lord, thank you for the five.
Literally.
Halo Live, real.
Halo Infinite Stream.
You want to play Halo Infinite?
I'm probably going to end up playing the Halo, so...
Sheevie is interested in playing shooters.
And I am going to...
I basically was like, please play Halo with me.
I would love to play Halo with you because it is multiplayer.
We've got Portal 2 on the card, so I can keep up my puzzle game meme.
Because Sheevie hasn't played Portal 2, and I'm like, oh my god, I played it, so we'll zoom through it.
Surely I'm not going to completely forget all the rooms.
I'm going to completely forget, and we're going to have to try and actually do it for real for real.
I warned her.
I said the full stream is probably five hours if you want to do it in one big block,
or if you'd rather spread it out.
Co-op campaign.
What about the tentacle that goes and hooks your mouth?
Eh?
What, you want me to commission that?
I commissioned...
I might as well, actually, you know what?
Don't be surprised if I just start spamming tons of stuff on the alt Twitter
to show you what I've been sitting on for ages.
Because I commissioned a ton of cute stuff of us together.
I have one where we're holding hands,
but it's like lude because you're a tentacle,
and I'm like, ah, hand-holding is so lude.
I'll need to make it.
Mytica's hot.
There's art in the vault.
So I knew what you looked like maybe...
Maybe eight months ago?
I knew what you looked like.
I knew what your name was.
And let's just say the temptation to order artwork of us,
doing stuff and all that, it was too much.
It was too much.
So I've got loads of stuff of us.
We were born eight months ago, honestly.
What about an audio of you being so busy with the lure
that you don't have time to spend with your reeflings?
You let us scrape you as an apology.
A reefling? You're not supposed to say that part aloud!
Thank you, Group Bavila.
I would have to be very cautious with the words.
How about we say the use of free?
How about that? The use of free instead?
So how about...
Wait, do you want Shibi to be in the background
and I'm actually talking about work stuff
with Shibi being like, here's these strategies.
I think if you do some of this stuff,
and your shorts are doing fantastic, you're doing great.
And then all you hear is like, plop, plop, plop.
And then Shibi's on the other side, like,
mushy, mushy, what's that noise in the background, scrawny?
And I'm just like, oh, it's nothing!
I think, do you have to ask,
I feel like Shibi would be down for something so silly like that.
This is a banger, and I know bangers!
Please!
She'd be into it, she'd laugh so hard.
You can also make it a de-interest.
That would be so good.
I'll see, I'll see.
We'll need a bit of time to cook,
because Shibi's actually doing some really good stuff
coming up soon, TM.
Which is not, I can't believe it.
It's not my place to leak what she's doing.
Doing it live.
I don't think I would get it live in the...
So I record in an audio booth.
I'm actually going to show you my audio booths for my donathon.
One of the rewards is like my, my buck-ass POV of how I record.
Call and ask her.
You want me to call her right now?
I can't call her right now, she's trying to stay upstream.
Shawnee, when she can leak insider information,
literally type in like,
sad Spider-Man walking away gif.
That's literally me when I can't leak absolutely everything that goes on.
Like when Umi came in to chat,
and she was like,
I can't hold stuff in either.
I'm like, she understands.
She gets it.
Do it, do it.
What, you want me to call Sheepster?
I'll message her.
Uh...
The reeflings want me to call you for a proposal.
Pre-re-o-pe-o-zo, but...
Oh no, this is dead off.
Oof.
I've messin'.
Uh...
I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
I think she's...
Yes, yes, what the ID...
Ears fall through.
Oh wait, did she say...
I think Sheep is having connectivity issues.
Hmm.
Oh, wait, Tor.
Uh...
Oh, she's yapping!
Oh my God, sorry, let me delete it.
Oh my God, let me delete it.
She's on Twitter.
She's doing a space on Twitter.
Sorry, reeflings.
I don't know, so can she not?
Is she having connections?
I think she's having a major connection, I think.
Sorry, sorry.
Uh, hopefully she didn't read that or else.
I'm in mild trouble.
I don't want to interrupt her if she's doing something.
I don't know what's been on her...
Whipsies!
I don't want to distract her if she's doing something like that, let's see.
Right, yes, she's on Twitter right now in a space if you want to listen.
Uh...
I don't know if I can redirect into her then.
Well, I will redirect into her chat, but is she cancelling?
Can someone ask if she's cancelling?
Because I'll redirect into Emma's...
Cross-platform raid?
I don't know if that's even possible.
Amy be heeee!
E-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e-e
Uh, Amy's playing Wizard 101?
What is this game?
Wizard 101?
Play Wizard 101 today.
It's a 2008 massively multiplayer online role-playing game
developed and published by King's Ayo Entertainment.
Players take on the role of student wizards who must save the spiral, the fictional universe in which the game is set from various threads.
Is it baby world of warcraft?
I love the game.
She's having internet issues right now.
Aww.
You don't know what wizard want to want it?
No, I'm sorry.
Is it like spore and everyone knows it?
It's basically the child version of why-
Okay, if you say it like that then yeah.
Aww.
There's like koala bears in it and stuff.
And an hour?
An hour?!
Oh my gosh, I have a DM on Twitter.
I'm getting so scared.
I'm getting scared.
Oh my gosh, it's another Vtuber.
I'm gonna ask her for a cheeky ASMR club.
If she's down, of course.
If she's down.
Wow is the child version of wow.
One over.
She said I heard wow on my ears.
Perrie's out!
I say carry me in wow but I don't understand what's going on half the time.
I'm just here for a good time.
Ask her for an ASMR club.
Don't deliver the lines for six months.
Honestly me, I feel really bad.
So Poseidon from Mythos sent me her lines ages ago
and I've been needing to record the stock sounds.
Like the stock sounds, no.
The actual sound effects that are written into the script.
But the problem is, it's been so fucking windy
that my bloody boost doesn't hide the wind sound.
So it's like even inside the damn thing.
So yeah.
And here goes Mummy looking for collabs.
She's looking for Pokemon.
I'm really happy when someone reaches out to me and asks for one
because I hope folk don't think I'm taking the pispy and like,
oh you're a beach over with the 3DO.
But I don't know.
I feel like I'm just so direct and forward like that.
I just hope folk aren't like, oh my god, Stroney's so weird about it.
But I don't know how else I'm supposed to go around it.
Like Yumi was really nice and reached out to me.
And she was like, I heard Stroney wants to do like ASMR collabs
and I'm like, fuck yeah, let me add you the fuck.
Let me write that whole damn thing.
Oh my god, is that, is that the real Yumi lurking in the shadows?
Real, real?
Is that the real Yumi?
I think it is as well.
No, sure, that's actually you.
It fucking is you.
Right, that's the Yumi that, wait, hold on.
Let me give you a spanner so we can actually see you.
Because you're hidden.
You're so hidden.
I'm a lurker, I feel bad chatting.
Lomo.
It's the Yumi.
So she's a demon girl.
Right, hold on.
Add as a motor here so we can actually see you.
Um, Yumi, I think you're actually the first person out of 20 planned
collabs to ask me, which is really nice.
It's actually really nice.
So yeah, Yumi ASMR now, average Johnny Collab.
It kind of is though because I, you know, I don't even want to be like
fucking around with someone like making small talk when it's not enough,
not in a rude way of being like not taking the time to invest or learn about
someone because I do look at people's content.
I do look at them and that before I message them.
And I was scared to ask you, but I'm so happy I reached out.
Thank you.
And Mummy's reputation is growing.
Having someone that asks, literally, I don't want to,
the reason why I do it so directly is I don't want to waste anyone's time.
I don't want to be like, oh, you need to learn about me before you
collab about me.
You need to, you know, XYZ Elemental P.
No, I'm like, hi, I'm Johnny from Veiler.
You know, I saw you have, you do ASMR streams.
I was wondering if you would like to collab.
I'll write the script.
I'll edit it, all that jazz.
And that's it.
That's literally how I communicate.
And either, you know, you get what you want or you give.
Don't get what you want.
So Shibi's going to try and stream again in a bit from what servers are down
and she'll try and stream at around 8 p.m.
Is it Tuesday?
Wait, how are servers are down for Doom?
No ASMR is Mega Man's there.
Well, Yumi, actually Yumi, I'm leaking her DMs.
So Yumi said something that made me think she doesn't have a 3Dio
and I was about to post the water white meme, like,
falling over like, you don't have a 3Dio?
Oh no, because I only, I only want to collab with a 3Dio
because that's how it sounds like much better than like,
versus like, if someone was using an SMB or whatever.
It's Wednesday.
What happens on a Wednesday?
Crazy how lots of underground streamers are coming out of the woodwork to work the wheeler.
I think people are nice about us, like,
so obviously a lot of management's agencies, like,
tell them not to interact with us because of the public perception,
which is fine, I respect it.
It's not, you know, don't hate the player, hate the game type thing.
But like, obviously indie v-tubers that do their own thing,
if they want to associate with us, they can associate with us.
It's not a problem, like, you can hang out at any time,
you know?
Wait, what?
Is there a DDoS attack going on?
Am I about to be booted offline?
Oh, so everyone's getting updated?
It could be Shibu's villain or a v-roo-o-o.
Eh.
Huh.
I'm picking my lip right now.
I said what I said.
I love a good lip picking.
That's just so good.
Did we dare look at Marshmallows?
I'm scared to.
Without picking your lip, but it's so, it feels so pleasurable, okay?
Sorry, you don't have a 3D.
I can't collab with you.
Collaborate with KU100 crying.
Bruh, she would completely, like, and just,
that's just her collab at that point.
I'm going to speak, like, one sentence, and I'm going to be like,
please, ladies and gentlemen, enjoy this girl.
KU100?
I don't understand why that is.
It's not like you guys are a litany person.
It's just perception.
Like, obviously, the first thing most people probably saw was
the first AVTuber company, EnglishTuber company type thing.
So, I completely understand why I'm not pissed around him like that.
Like, it just says that it is what it is.
Your lips seem dry.
Let me fix that.
Pucker up.
I'm still picking, sorry.
Check the marshmallows and laugh for a bit.
What made me really push the barrel and reaching out?
I wanted to before, but I thought I'd get ignored.
Was the collab you did with them, Paul?
Oh, the alien one?
What I like to do is write the ASMR collabs,
either related to the girl in some way,
or if they have previous ASMR stuff,
I try to incorporate what their most popular plot is.
This girl was really kind and collaborated with me.
She agreed to do ASMR,
but she actually does ASMR roleplays on her side.
And one of them was Lovebombing, a type of roleplay.
And I was like, because you're this,
do you want to do a Lovebombing type of plot together?
And she was like, fuck yeah!
And she was just happy because I was incorporating stuff
that she had done before and that was successful.
Because obviously I want the success of the video
and the collab partner gets shown off
and I get to, you know, get a little bit closer to them,
my goals and stuff.
They're scared of catching cooties from the Shlife, honestly.
How do I find the alt Twitter?
I think I'm just called strongy...
Not safe, really?
I can't remember.
Big dub for indie YouTubers.
Yeah, like it's really nice
how many people have agreed to do collabs with me.
Um, because there's now a third editor on board,
I'm actually really happy.
I've got two ASMR milestone videos coming out.
The next collab is with Poseidon.
I just need to record the sound effect.
I'm feeling cheeky though,
because I saw Shibi got a bowl with wooden balls
to like make soup ASMR.
So it's going to be a lot better than mine.
And I'm tempted to be like,
oh Shibi, do you like even more work on your play?
What sold me was the Sonic Tizm,
if I'm being brutally honest.
Sonic Heroes.
I didn't even know Sonic Heroes had that hidden end in Yumi,
so if you've not played it on stream,
I heavily recommend it.
I'm not even that good at Sonic
because I'm not very skilled at it,
but even I could do it.
So it went fantastically astic.
Oh no, Shibi DM'd me.
Oh no, she sent me the rock!
I was going to ask for a quick voice chat for...
Oh my God, I'm sweating.
I feel like I'm in trouble.
And I saw you were in Twitter space.
Oh no, oh no.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, I'm getting scared.
How am I even going to phrase this?
Oh hi Shibi, would you like to be on the other end of an audio
where the reeflings are shagging me?
How else do I phrase it?
Hello, hello Shibi.
Why yes, it is I, Strony.
Hi Shibi.
Hello, we can hear you.
How are you?
I'm, I'm mad.
Oh my freaking internet.
I'm so upset.
Your internet, her internet shit in the bed?
Yeah, like, you know how when I was in call with you
and Mercy the other day and our stuff,
just like I just kept like not being able to hear anything.
Disappear in for like five minutes.
Yeah, I'm like, they're just like having a whole conversation
and I'm like, what did you guys say?
I said, can you repeat that for the back of the class?
Thanks.
What do the reeflings want to know?
Um, we have a question that's rather unique
and we've embarrassed that.
Are you asking me on a date?
Cause it's yes.
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, I mean, I'll take it.
We have a date on portal too, actually.
I've already, I'm sorry, I already leaked it.
Forgive me, I'm not worthy.
I was wondering if in theory I were to create a scripts
where the reeflings were helping me with stress relief
whilst I may or may not be giving you content creator advice
in the background.
And then basically you kind of go, huh, Strani, what's going on?
You're making some weird noises and I'm like, nothing.
You want me to be cocked over the phone?
A wee bit, a wee bit if you say it like that.
Oh my God.
If I, if I wrote a wee silly gooberino of a script like that,
do you think you'd be down to be on the other side?
Yeah, sure.
We can do it right now.
I could be like, what are you talking about?
Strani, what, I think you're breaking.
What's that noise?
You're like, pure, pure, pure, pure, pure.
Sorry, I'm just, I'm just caught talking something the last now.
Oh, sorry, I just stubbed my toe hand, didn't you worry?
Did you worry about me?
Oh my God.
Okay, that's a yes.
Holy fuck.
10 out of 10 for Shibi.
Right, let us bring to the internet.
God, she can boot up because I'm redirecting into that.
Yes.
Oh, I hope fully.
I hope it works and like.
Are you doing like speed tests and stuff?
I just like, I, it, everything looks normal.
Stuff just keeps falling off.
Like my whole entire last part of my Elden Ring stream
just completely lagged and bugged out.
I don't know why.
And that's why I think it's like something's going on in my building.
Well, some of the reeflands we're seeing servers are getting updated
in other places of dust interwebs.
I don't know if maybe you're like,
because you're a region lock, then maybe it's having.
Maybe.
Like maybe it's like just little hiccups.
Perhaps.
Hopefully it goes away.
It seems like it's fine now.
Well, literally you've not lagged for a little second.
Yeah, I'm like, hello?
Is it safe?
Yeah, I know.
I don't know.
Are you still in Twitter space?
Did it lag out at all on Twitter?
Oh, no, I'm on 5G right now on Twitter.
Oh, dumb ass, of course you are.
Because why would you randomly have an ethernet cable plugged into your mobile phone?
Yeah.
That would be impressive.
That, yeah, technology sure has come a long way.
But yes, right.
I am going to thank you for even entertaining something so ridiculous.
I'm always down to clown.
I hope, yeah.
And I'm going to go and then stall and see if we can get you up,
because I would like to redirect into you.
Okay, okay.
I'll try.
I'll talk to you later, alligator.
Okay, bye.
Bye, bye.
Yeah, I'm so fucking embarrassed.
I'm so fucking embarrassed.
Oh, hey, Sheebie.
Would you like to be fucking on the other side of the microphone?
Bruh.
Hi.
Please, I'm balling my eye.
What does that even mean?
I think Amazon servers hosting is having problems,
which is affecting all these different locations.
I can't believe my joke of an idea just created this masterpiece of a script.
Did I cook or did I fucking cook?
You motherfucking cooked.
I sure you motherfucking cooked.
Uh, baby, you're the greatest time of my life.
Thank you, Grimdy Bealer.
Yes, as I said, I'm always open to the content that you want to see.
Please don't ever be like, oh, I'm not having anything.
I don't know.
That amount of money I would pay to see.
My face is red like a freaking tomato right now.
I'm not even kidding.
Hey, Sheebie, can you sit in that chair for a second?
Just for a moment.
I like how innocent she is.
She's like, are you asking me on a date?
And I'm like, uh, kind of if you want to think of it like a video.
But yes, I, as I said, I'm always open to that stuff.
I prefer making content you actually want to see than taking a stab in the dark.
So I have roughly 10 ASMRs to upload.
And then I'm going to start doing what you guys want me to do for the milestones.
Hey, Sheebie, please listen to us doing the deed, basically.
More embarrassed than mommy.
I'm morphed.
It's a date if you're into it, Tim.
A date, but she's the third wheel.
Is she the third wheel or is she the third thingy?
I think how I'll do it is I'll start it off and she is in the call.
And then eventually she hangs up and then I start getting fricking raging at you.
And I'm like, because you guys seem to want me to shout at you angrily in my accent in
audios.
So I think what we'll do is we hang up, like means she be hanging up.
And then basically I'll whip around and give you daggers.
And I'm like, what the fuck are you playing at?
But then obviously I'm enjoying it.
So then I keep getting angry.
Another thought is she figures that out and starts teasing you too.
The collabs didn't do how I expected, like I predicted them to do.
So in the audio role play VA world, it's actually really good when two people
collab together because it's like, oh my god, really exciting that these two,
these two forces have come together to fight in the same team.
Um, I missed the mark with the VTuber side of it.
And I was like, oopsies, whoopsies.
So I'm probably not really going to do that too much.
Oh, hey, our game is on pause.
We're on day eight.
How are we doing gas stations in there?
Am I just starving at all times?
Feels like I'm just starving at all times.
Starving Marvin.
I'll let you look at something a wee bit different in the background.
How about with some blabbing away?
This turned into a script writing stream.
Real and true, VA lord.
I actually did really well in my last membership script writing stream.
I'm like, don't you mind if I do?
Don't you mind if I do?
Um, yeah, happens the favorite part.
Then she grapes those.
I grape you.
I'm a great piece so hard.
Uh, no, but as I said, I'm always like down to plan when it comes to that stuff.
Right.
I'm going to dare to look at Marshmallow.
And before the first thing is like, oh, well, I'm triggered.
Hi, strongers.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Get praise, get praise, get praise.
Love you.
Love you too.
Are you filming?
And uh, can you see can I?
Please artwork me.
I don't know how we even got there.
Now that I think about it, I'm like, how did we even get there?
Oh my God.
Oh, jump scared.
Well, she bees up.
She bees up.
Are you ready?
Anonymous.
She be what are those wet noises?
Mama nothing.
What are those wet noises?
Yeah, I think my microphone's bugging out.
This is an older SMB, you know.
Shawnee, we should play Black Ops 3 Zombies together.
We can do Shadow of Evil.
You may, you have more experience than that than me.
I've not even played Zombies in Black Ops 3.
Um, I'm not even kidding right now.
So you'd literally be showing me the ropes if we're doing that.
If we're down to clown, I'm down to clown.
You just need to send me a DM.
Right.
I am going to prepare to redirect into she be my timbers.
Any timberinos.
So tomorrow, the agenda is actually a collab.
Oh my God, I'm so social.
I'm such a social being.
And I'm going to have to behave.
I'm going to have to be respectful.
Oh, I can't believe I'm always, I'm, I'm hopefully I'm always respectful.
Anyway, you're taking my ASMR collab for Jennie.
I'm taking your Zombies on Black Ops 3.
Damn, I come back at the end.
Yeah, it wasn't a long story today.
Not long story today.
Okay.
Ah, I'm gonna redirect into she be.
She's currently a positive.
I know like when she's a floating head right now.
Is she strewn from her phone?
I'm a floating head.
Hi there.
Hi.
Are we welcome to the void?
I don't know what she's up to.
I'm just let her do her shenanigans.
As long as she's happy, I'm happy.
Noises aren't anything suspicious.
Just making a nice cream pie filling over here.
Thank you for this theme.
Thank you for licking in the shadow.
I don't think I did a Vod watcher reward.
I don't, I don't recall.
Right.
I'm a...
What is she doing?
I don't know.
I'm gonna redirect into she be,
but she has an internet connection issue.
So please don't be too panicky if it doesn't work.
The she be's testing some things.
Even the truth she do is giving her the stinger with.
Oh yeah.
Did you see the stinger?
Are you ready?
Are you ready for the stinger?
Whoa.
Oh my gosh.
I'm such a professional strummer.
Look at that.
And that's not even the other one.
My other one is doesn't even work.
There's a second one that doesn't even work.
I'm so professional.
It's real.
Oh my god.
Wait until I start doing my emotes as well.
Wow.
Oh my god.
What?
I just realized my head is being clipped off as well.
So unprofessional honestly.
You know what it is?
It's a freaking beach of studio.
Always wants to change its resolution or something.
No.
That's still getting clipped off.
I didn't even notice that the entire stream.
Well, I'm off to pop my clog.
And that's that.
I'm gonna redirect into she be.
I don't know what Shan Nanagan she's getting up to,
but please enjoy her with your heart's content.
I will see you tomorrow for a collaboration stream
and then a membership stream afterwards.
I don't know what we're going to do.
I think it's members ace more.
No.
I'm going to have to try harder.
Ace has so far.
Okay.
I'll survive.
Bye bye reflames.
I'll see you cutie but hoody some more.
I'll give you my key.
I'm only level three in gas station simulator,
so I can only give three kisses.
So a YAP stream.
No.
A tingle stream.
I promise it's a tingle stream.
Okay.
There you.
I'm going to tingle you so hard.
I'm going to tingle all over you.
Right.
I am going to go and rest.
I'm going to get sleep and then I'm going to wake up
and then hopefully I'll have some ace more for you
for two days in a boot.
Okay.
Bye bye reflames.
And you may if you're still lurking
since you're too shy to type.
Bye reflames.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Bye bye.
Love you.
See you tomorrow.
Enjoy Shabby.
Say hi to Shabby.